MARY KATE: Hello, and
welcome to Authors at Google.
I am super excited
to be here today
to introduce "Profit
from the Positive."
And I'm not just saying
that because I read the book
and learned that it's best
to start with a sizzle.
I'm saying that because the book
is actually quite excellent.
I am a researcher here at
the People and Innovation lab
at Google, where
my job has defined
new ways to use social science
to create one of the best
places to be a creative worker.
And in my role here,
I am constantly
looking for new Google-y
ways to make our company
a more amazing place to work.
And it is my pleasure to
be introducing this talk,
because this book is full of
ideas on how to do just that.
Senia Maymin, an executive coach
and founder of two startups,
and Margaret Greenberg, founder
of the consulting and coaching
practice, the Greenberg Group,
have scoured the research
and come up with concise
answer to the question,
how can we get people to
perform at their best?
And their answer is by
identifying, cultivating,
and using their
strengths every day.
Creating roles,
work relationships,
and organizations
where people can
do that while under intense
pressure to innovate
is not easy.
And this book isn't
the silver bullet.
But it does offer
a silver lining.
Creative new ways of approaching
day-to-day management
challenges by focusing on what
drives employee engagement.
I look forward to learning more.
Join me in welcoming
Senia and Margaret.
[APPLAUSE]
SENIA MAYMIN: Hello, hello.
Hello, Google.
We're very excited to talk
to you about the book.
And specifically, to
give you three tools
that you can walk away with.
As you see in the
subtitle of the book,
we have Boost Productivity,
Transform Your Business.
So you're literally going to
walk out of here with tools
to help you amp up
your productivity
and your influence.
The book has a few
different components
that you may have
already heard about.
But basically, it takes
the latest research,
just like Mary Kate just said.
And it uses over
30 practical tools.
And one thing that
you'll see throughout,
and you'll see throughout
what we're telling you,
is that there are real
life case studies.
Both what Margaret
and I have experienced
as we've been executive
coaches and have
worked with people who
want more productivity, who
want more influence.
And as an aside, we
actually often find
that the people who want
to be most productive
are those people
who already are.
So when we ask people, what
do you really want to do?
The ones who say they
want more productivity,
they tend to already
be more productive.
As an example of the
real-life case studies,
you'll see that in the
book, in Chapter Five,
which is the hiring chapter.
The first part is what
you can do for yourself.
And the second part
of the book are
common problems, common
issues, such as hiring,
how to bring out the
best performance reviews.
So you will see that we featured
Google highly in the hiring
chapter.
What other company has
a term like Google-y?
That is just really
neat that you
think about hiring in
a specific way that's
very specific to you.
The other example of a very
strong company that does that
is Zappos.
And for them, the
word is "more weird."
More weird is what's
important to them.
But not too weird,
not too little weird.
So it's very important
to think about culture.
And you'll see that in
the Chapter Five section.
Today, what are we
really talking about?
We're talking about getting more
done, but without necessarily
working more hours.
So what can we do?
Before we do this,
I want to tell you
a little bit about
what is this thing that
is our time pressure to succeed.
Americans work eight hours
more per week than Germans,
but we are no more
productive, unfortunately.
If you look around the room,
7 of the 10 people around you
will tell you that work is
a major source of stress.
Maybe not here,
maybe not at Google,
as there are a lot of
people working on it.
But this is a
national statistic.
There has been a
time diary study
done by sociologists since 1965
that literally has measured
what do people do and how
do they spend their time?
And from 1965 until today, we
have only one additional hour
of free time.
Now, how great or
not great is that?
We have great technology.
We have multiple ways
that we can get more time.
But we're not getting
that much more time.
So if you liked listening
to music in 1965,
and you like listening
to that same music now,
you only have one
more hour to do it.
This is a major concept
that Margaret and I
talk about with
every single company
that we have worked with.
Which is flip-flop costs.
You may be more familiar with
the term as multitasking.
We all do it.
I do it.
You do it.
Everybody multitasks.
The part about multitasking
that you may not
know about is
multitasking can be fine,
but it's the switching
cost, that flip-flop cost.
So flipping from one
project to another.
And that's the
part that actually
decreases your
productivity by 40%.
The book is called "Profit
from the Positive."
We want you to profit
financially, emotionally,
mentally from these
tools that you're
going to walk out of here with.
But what is this positive
thing that we have there?
So I'll tell you
first what it's not.
I'm going to give
you the bartender's
guide to positive psychology.
So when people see
the word "positive,"
they often think,
oh, smiley faces.
They think this is a
rosy-eyed view of the world.
Sometimes people
think, oh, that is
and that should be the
glass-half-full mentality.
But no.
It's actually the
disturbing-the-water part
of the glass.
That's what we think
positive psychology is.
Positive psychology
is an academic study.
And it's basically saying,
OK, glass half full.
There's the water level.
But how can we study
that water level?
How can we figure
out what really
does make people
optimistic, what
really does make
people more resilient?
Another thing that
people sometimes
say about positive
psychology is,
oh, you mean that
kind of thing where
I sit around doing
gratitude mantras
and I try to really make
lemonade out of lemons?
And we say, no.
Please don't necessarily
try to do that.
One of the things that you
may very well want to do
is you may want to take
just part of that lemon,
and squeeze it
into a lime drink.
Do something totally different.
So not necessarily that positive
means smiling and always good.
One thing that you will
not walk out of here with
is you will not walk out
of here with this attitude
that, I now feel more positive
about my productivity,
and therefore I am.
That's not what's
going to happen.
So now that I've told
you all these things
that positive psychology is not,
what is positive psychology?
It's basically the
study of what's right.
What do I mean by that?
It's the study of what's
right in relationships,
in personal fulfillment, in
business, in productivity.
And it's when you look at
those things that are working.
So let me give you an example.
Take off your Google
hats for moment,
and put on your architect hat.
So pretend that you are
a British architect.
And you are out to make the best
bridges that you can possibly
make.
You have at least two different
things that you can do.
You can look at all the
bridges that have fallen
and collapsed, and
are not standing,
and the suspension
has gone wrong.
Or you can look at
all the bridges that
have withstood the test of
time, that have been standing
for decades, centuries,
maybe thousands of years.
Now, one thing we're
saying is don't not
study the bridges
that have collapsed.
That's a very, very
important thing to do.
We're good at problem solving.
That's an important thing to do.
But also look at the
bridges that have
withstood the test of time.
Why?
Because you're
not going to learn
the same lessons from both.
So researchers in
social psychology
have studied bad marriages.
And they found that
in bad marriages
there are a lot of arguments.
So you might make the
conclusion that you
might want to not have
arguments in order
to have a good marriage.
But researchers have
studied good marriages,
and they found that
in good marriages
there are a lot of arguments.
It's just, how do you
get past the arguments?
How do you resolve them?
So what we're saying is, also
study the strong bridges.
These three tools.
I'm going to give
you a shortcut,
and they won't mean
anything to you right now.
But at the end, they'll
mean everything to you.
Trick Yourself.
FRE, which is actually free.
And that means
Don't Be an Expert.
Let's start with Trick Yourself.
This is what we hear
as executive coaches.
We hear our clients,
who are already
highly successful people,
saying to us, I'm stuck.
I'm not sure how to start.
Or saying to us, it's important.
I know this thing is important.
But I just get too busy
working on other things.
So what do we tell them to do?
One of the things that we try to
put into their toolkit is this.
Imagine.
Imagine that you are in
an experimental room,
and a social psychologist has
come up to you and has said,
this is how we'll
run this experiment
that you've agreed
to participate in.
I'm going to give you 20
activities, one by one.
Each one of them will take
about three to five minutes.
And I want you to do them
as I bring you new ones.
So I might ask you
to make a puzzle.
I might ask you to
make a clay figure.
Say I'll give you some
yellow and brown clay.
I might ask you to
fold the cardboard box.
I might ask you to do
some different activities.
Now, unbeknownst to you as
you start this experiment,
at some point, the
experimenter will come in
and will actually
interrupt your activity
and tell you that it's time
to go on to the next one.
So it might be that
you're doing an anagram,
and experimenter comes in
and says, OK, that's enough.
Let's go on to the next one.
Or it might be that you're doing
a crossword puzzle or LEGOs,
and the experimenter comes
in and says, let's move on.
Now, here's a question for you.
At the end of the
experiment, the experimenter
will ask you, which
ones do you remember?
So he'll actually say,
do you remember the ones
that you were interrupted?
He'll say, which
ones do you remember?
And I want you to list them.
So my question to
you is, do you think
you're more likely to
remember the interrupted ones?
And let's say the jigsaw
puzzle, the little giraffe,
and the anagrams
are the interrupted,
and the other ones
are the completed.
Or do you think you're
more likely to remember
the completed ones?
AUDIENCE: Interrupted.
SENIA MAYMIN: Interrupted.
So let's get some comments.
Why did somebody
say "interrupted?"
Why?
AUDIENCE: Your brain
is still working on it.
SENIA MAYMIN: Your brain
is still working on them.
What else?
AUDIENCE: More disturbing.
SENIA MAYMIN: More disturbing?
How disturbing?
AUDIENCE: Disturbing
that I'm not done yet.
SENIA MAYMIN: Not done yet.
I want to do something else.
Your brain is working on them.
It's more disturbing.
Who has a comment on
the completed ones?
That you spent
more time on them?
This room votes
interrupted, yes?
This whole room
is entirely right.
The interrupted tasks
were remembered so much so
that they were-- the room is
high-fiving each other, just
for the record.
They were remembered so much
so that they were remembered
90% of the time more
than the completed tasks.
Now, that's a little bit funny.
I know the room
doesn't think so.
But it's a little bit funny.
Because you actually
had the chance
to spend more time on
the completed tasks.
What's happening?
It's exactly what the two
people here in the front said.
It's that when you leave
things unfinished, really,
the way that the
experimenter described it,
is there's a tension.
There's a tension in your head.
That's unfinished, how
do I get back to it?
It's still rolling
around in your head.
Now if you're at
a cocktail party
and you want to
be really snazzy,
this is called the
Zeigarnik Effect,
for the researcher
who created it.
So the fact that you
want to come back
to things that were unfinished.
Let's take you to a
different place-- car washes.
Who needs to go to a car wash?
I needed to last week.
Car washes.
Suppose you have one of
these two sets of car washes.
You've gone to a car wash.
You've driven by, you've
gone to a car wash.
And you think, OK, I
got a car wash here.
And at the end, the
person at the car wash
gives you a coupon.
The person gives you
either this coupon.
So this coupon has
eight little places
that you have to stamp before
you can get the ninth free car
wash.
Or the person gives
you this coupon,
in which there are
10 places to stamp
before you get
the 11th car wash.
But notice that the first
two are stamped out.
Another question for you.
In which one of these do you
think you would go all the way
and go to, in effect,
nine car washes
to get your free car wash?
The one with--
AUDIENCE: Two stamps.
SENIA MAYMIN: With
the two stamps.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because it's that
they already give us something.
SENIA MAYMIN: They
give you something.
Almost like something free?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they give
something with the [INAUDIBLE].
SENIA MAYMIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: I agree, but I think
the reason that I would say,
because the process
already started.
So leaving the
second one would feel
like wasting the two car washes.
SENIA MAYMIN: So
there's a comment
that it feels like you're
wasting the two car
washes that you
didn't actually do,
but that you may be wasting.
Did you have a comment here?
AUDIENCE: Similar.
SENIA MAYMIN: Similar comment.
And what did you want to say?
AUDIENCE: I think
also, you don't
need to get over
any mental hurdle,
because the decision has
been made for you already.
SENIA MAYMIN: The decision
has been made for you.
You don't need to get
over any mental hurdle.
You guys are right on.
So either you've read the
book, or you're right in line
with the thinking
of the psychologist.
Basically, 300 people--
about 150 in each group--
went through 19%
of that group where
they had to get eight stamps
to get the free ninth one.
19% of that went
all the way through.
Of the other group, 32%.
So there's something
about having started.
There's something about that.
We'll give you an
example of something
we see in our coaching.
We see that when somebody needs
to put a presentation together,
or put a report together,
sometimes they'll just start
and then step away from it.
So literally plan that they
will step away from it.
They kind of trick themselves.
Or something that's in the
book is one of our clients
writes a to-do list, but she
writes the first two items
and immediately
crosses them off.
It's a little funny, right?
It's like you're very, very
physically tricking yourself.
So now a question for you.
And I'll give you the
very specific ways
that you can approach
the question.
This is my favorite
page in the book.
It's page 17.
It's 5-1-smallest.
It's just like all the
things that you've described.
But there are really
three questions
to be able to get yourself
to that trick-yourself state.
5-1-smallest.
What can I do in five minutes?
What can I do to move the
project forward by 1%?
And what's the
smallest action I can
take for the biggest impact?
They're very simple questions,
but sometimes simplicity
can make us take a step forward.
I'd like you to
look around the room
and choose somebody who
you didn't walk in with,
and to turn to that person.
And I'm going to give you about
a minute and a half per person.
And to turn to that
person and to tell
them, what is a project--
Ideo tends to do this.
They tend to really,
really trick themselves
into getting started.
Let me just give you this.
Today is Tuesday.
For everybody watching online
as well, today is Tuesday.
It will always be Tuesday when
you watch this presentation.
This week, on what
project do I need
to trick myself into
getting started?
So you already
know what that is.
So tell a partner what that is.
And ask yourself, and
have the partner ask you,
how can I apply this five
minutes, 1%, smallest action
principle?
Please go ahead.
And both ways.
You and then the other person.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SENIA MAYMIN: OK,
let's come back.
Who would like to share
a trick-yourself example?
So either the project
or what you've
thought of that you can
do to trick yourselves.
So I would love a
couple of volunteers
to share their
project and what it
is that you thought
to trick yourself in.
Five minutes, 1%,
or smallest thing.
MARGARET GREENBERG: OK.
SENIA MAYMIN: This is Margaret.
MARGARET GREENBERG:
I'm Margaret.
Hi.
One of the things that we
did is we wrote every Friday.
We had a meeting at
one o'clock Eastern.
I'm on the east coast.
SENIA MAYMIN: Margaret's in
Connecticut, I'm in California.
MARGARET GREENBERG: And so we
had this meeting every Friday
by phone.
And what I would do
is I would send Senia
an email on all that I
accomplished that day.
Whether I rewrote a chapter,
or did a piece of research.
But when did I write the email?
I wrote it first
thing in the morning
at 7:30, as if I had already
completed all those things.
And then I hit the send button
at five minutes before one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SENIA MAYMIN: Wonderful.
The comment is he
was trying to do
yoga and meditation
every day, and he
found it hard to
commit to 90 minutes.
So he told himself
and started doing
one minute per day, 60 seconds.
You've done it for months now?
Fabulous.
There's some research
that if you're
trying to get into the habit
of flossing your teeth,
you really should
just floss one tooth.
It gets you started.
This was trick yourself
into getting started.
And now we're going
to move on to FRE.
And here's Margaret with that.
MARGARET GREENBERG:
Thank you Senia.
Thank you.
So here we go.
FRE-- Frequent Recognition
and Encouragement.
And guess what?
It really is free.
And what we're
talking about here
is not formal
recognition programs
that most companies have.
It's the informal recognition,
the expression of appreciation.
So what do we know about that?
Well, I'll tell you
a little story first.
There was a company that I
was coaching the president--
actually, here in California
now that I think about it.
And they had just
acquired another company.
And so we brought together the
leaders from both companies.
And we wanted to do an inventory
of all the management practices
that both companies had.
And so he asked the head of
HR from the other company,
so what kind of
management practices
do you have to improve the
performance of your employees?
And the head of HR said, we
have a progressive discipline
process.
So you can imagine,
I nearly fell off
my chair what I
heard that, right?
So I thought to
myself, well, imagine
if we had a progressive
feedback process.
What might that look like?
So we got curious.
Actually another colleague
of mine, Dana Arakawa, who
also went to UPenn
with Senia and me,
we got curious and decided
to conduct a study.
But think about it.
Progressive discipline.
That's like-- do we have
any golfers in the room?
That's like hiring of
golf pro who says just
before every swing, don't miss!
Don't miss!
Right?
So we said, there's
got be another way.
So we wanted to conduct a study.
So there was a company, another
high technology organization,
part of a large financial
services company.
The CIO was curious, too.
Was there any link
between giving
frequent recognition
and encouragement
and the performance of that
particular individual in team?
So one of the
things we often get
from clients is
they'll ask us, how
do I get the most out of people?
And we actually
suggest that they
ask themselves a somewhat
different question.
Not a question and
that sounds like you're
trying to squeeze every last
ounce out of an employee--
how do I get the most?
Instead, we suggest that
they ask this question.
How can we bring out the best?
Now.
You probably all know about
some of the Gallup research.
One of the ways to
bring out the best
is really to understand
and know your strengths
and get to use them every day.
How many people
have actually taken
some kind of
strengths assessment?
OK.
How many people actually
consciously apply
their strengths every day?
Great.
OK.
Keep working on it.
Well, another way that you
can really bring out the best
is by giving frequent
recognition and encouragement.
And again, it's free.
So this study was at a financial
services company technology
department.
About 900 technology employees,
about $100 million budget.
And so we decided
to see if there
was any link between
these positive practices,
like frequent recognition and
encouragement, and the results
that they got.
So what did we find out?
Well, one of the things--
and you probably know this,
working here at Google--
technology people
love to measure everything.
In fact, I like to say
if you can't measure it,
it doesn't exist.
They'll tell me,
if it doesn't fit
into a spreadsheet,
Margaret, it doesn't exist.
I'm like, well, maybe not.
So we were curious.
So we conducted this study
with about 155 IT folks.
Some of them were project
managers, architects, BAs,
et cetera.
And we wanted to see
what the connection was.
And the cool thing is they
had nine performance measures
that we didn't even
have to come up with.
Performance measures such
as were they on budget?
Were they on time, on schedule?
And what about quality,
the number of defects?
And they had another handful
of other performance measures
as well.
So we took a look at that.
And we created a survey.
And we asked questions
such as, my manager regular
recognizes project milestones?
And how frequent does your
manager recognize performance?
And some other follow-on
questions as well.
In fact, this particular
survey is actually
in the book in the appendix
that you can take yourself,
and can also have
others take it.
So what did we find out?
Well, we took the
employees' answers
to those questions and others.
And we were able to
actually rank the responses,
from those managers that
received really high scores
on frequent recognition
and encouragement
and those that
scored really low.
So we put it into the
quartiles, high to low.
And guess what we found?
We now have the data.
We actually saw a 42% increase
in the team performance
by those managers that
scored in that top quartile
for giving FRE than those
that scored in the bottom.
So it made a big
difference-- 42%.
So why don't we do, then?
Why don't we do either
peer-to-peer more often,
or manager direct report?
Why don't we do more of it?
Well.
There's a couple reasons why.
One.
We've been taught that there
are other productivity tools.
Are you familiar with Lean
Six Sigma and tools like that?
That to improve
productivity, you
have to measure the
work, the process.
Now, I wouldn't
want you to walk out
of here thinking that
Senia and I aren't
in favor of improving process.
We are.
In fact, I spent a
good part of the '90s
doing process re-engineering.
So I'm intimately
familiar with it.
| you're missing out on a big
part of the results equation
when you don't also
look at the worker.
How can we improve performance
through some of our practices?
Negativity bias.
That's a term psychologists
use to describe
why we don't do
certain things, why
we tend to look at the
glass as half empty.
Some evolutionary
psychologists believe
that for early
man to survive, he
had to be on the lookout for
that saber toothed tiger, not
a beautiful sunset.
So we are often keen
to finding fault.
We are more apt to catch people
doing things wrong than we
are to catch them
doing things right.
Think about, you're all probably
familiar with those customer
service stats.
Where when we have poor
service, we tell 13 people.
But what we have seller
service, we only tell five.
So we're hard-wired to
look at what's wrong.
So giving positive feedback
doesn't come easily
to some people.
And then lastly,
we've heard just
about every excuse in
our coaching practices
on why people don't do it.
And here are a couple
of our favorites.
"I'm too busy." "That's
what they get paid to do."
"I don't like encouragement
or need it to do my job."
Then we show them the data.
"It's too early to celebrate."
we hear this all the time,
especially from
technology organizations
that have these multimillion
dollar multi-year projects.
We don't know if
it's implemented yet,
so we've got to wait.
No, don't wait.
And then lastly, this is
really one of our favorites.
"It'll go to their heads."
Come on!
So the question is,
how do you encourage
more positive feedback, when it
may not be part of the culture?
And one of the
things we talk about
in "Profit from the
Positive" is how
to become a positive deviant.
And the fact that you're
all here today, right here,
probably tells us
that you probably
waiver on that positive
deviant slide anyways.
So our recommendation would
be to just start doing it.
There is something called
in psychology the contagion
effect.
And it can work both
positively and negatively.
So the more we do it, it
creates this contagion effect.
Now, we'll get into
in a moment, you
have to make sure
it doesn't backfire.
And that's what this slide is.
You want to make sure that
the frequent recognition
and encouragement, there's
some parameters around it.
So this is our backfire slide.
Do we have any car
enthusiast in the room?
So first, one way to
prevent it from backfiring
is make sure that you're giving
process praise rather than
person praise.
So Carol Dweck, who some
of you know from Stanford,
has done a number of
research studies around this.
And what we mean by
that is person praise
is when we recognize someone
with really general statements.
Like Rebecca,
you're really smart.
Or Fay, great job.
The interesting thing that we've
found, or that Carol has found,
is that people that
give person praise,
it actually can create
a sense of helplessness.
And that they're afraid
to lose that distinction.
If we have anybody in the room
that has kids, remember that.
I wish I knew this
earlier in my motherhood.
The second.
Think about it this way.
Process praise is
when we praise someone
by actually describing the
process or the strategies
they used in completing
that particular project
or whatever it is you're
giving them feedback on.
So that's an important concept.
To say, I really appreciate that
you did that project for me,
or analyzed those
reports for me,
because I know you put in a lot
of time and a lot of effort.
And you have a lot of
other things on your plate,
so I really appreciate that
So whether that's peer-to-peer
or manager to direct report,
remember, process praise,
not person praise.
Second, are you familiar with
the term absent presence?
Absent presence.
It's what you do-- some of
you might be doing it right
now if you're on your iPhone.
Taking notes.
That's OK.
It's when we dial into
that conference call
and then we put the phone on
mute and we catch up on email.
Or it's when you're
out to dinner
with your spouse, lover,
partner, friend, whoever
and you're texting while
you're across from each other,
and you're really not present.
You're physically present,
but you're mentally absent.
So when it comes to
delivering FRE, to your point,
it has to be genuine.
Yes, it has to be specific,
but it needs to be genuine.
And one way to be
sure that it is
is that you're really present.
You give eye contact.
Even if it's feedback you're
giving remotely to somebody
in another location
or another country,
stop whatever you're doing,
turn away from your computer
if you're on the phone,
and really deliver it.
You can tell when people aren't
present even over the phone,
even over the computer.
And then lastly,
praise to the back.
This is a term that we
learned from one of the guys
we interviewed for "Profit
from the Positive."
He's actually the
co-founder and president
of EverFi, who Google actually
did early funding for.
So EverFi is a DC-based
web-based curriculum
for students--
both middle school,
high school, and college--
where they teach kids
financial literacy skills
and some other life skills,
anti-bullying kind of thing.
And one of the things
he talks about at EverFi
is it's easy to give people
direct feedback in an email
or face-to-face.
But oftentimes, we forget
about praising to the back.
When you're in a
meeting and you talk
about somebody who isn't there.
And it reverberates.
It comes back to that person.
Hey, I was in that meeting.
they were talking
about you, that you
did this really great
job on XYZ project.
They were really talking
about how valuable
you are to the company.
So praise to the back.
A couple other things.
Some companies that we
interviewed for the book
and have told some
stories around.
EverFi is one.
Zappos is another, out in Las
Vegas, that Senia visited.
And jwi-de-- jwi-de-- de va?
Joie de Vivre.
I'm better with my Spanish.
Another, we interviewed
Chip Conley for the book,
as well as Pizza
Hut and Taco Bell.
And probably, maybe Google,
too we may add to this list.
And this is a quote that we
love from one of the people
that we quote in the
book. "Using recognition
is the best way to build
a high-energy, fun culture
and reinforce the behaviors
that drive results.
Why be selfish on the one thing
that matters most to people?"
So with that, who have you
been meaning to give a FRE to?
Think about it for a moment.
And again, turn to the
person next to you.
Who have you been
meaning to give a FRE to?
It could be a peer.
Do we have any
managers in the room?
If you manage, it might
be somebody on your team
that you want to
give feedback to.
Maybe someone in
another department.
Someone you've been
meaning to give a FRE to.
So this one I'm only going
to give you 30 seconds.
And remember, the process.
What was the process?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARGARET GREENBERG:
How many people
are actually going to now
deliver that FRE when they
go back to their
desk after this talk?
That they'll
actually deliver it?
OK.
You can do better than that.
OK?
All right.
I'm going to turn it
back over to Senia
then, who's going to introduce
us to the third tool.
Go ahead.
SENIA MAYMIN: So
literally, in the book
we talk about it as Don't Quit,
Just Quit Being an Expert.
And it's really when we're
hearing from our clients,
this project is
extremely stressful.
I'm frustrated at
my own results.
I've been really trying.
Or, for example, in sales,
I've gotten six nos.
And now I'm about to
make a seventh call.
What mental state
should I be in?
This was not a good week.
So we all have these.
I have these.
You likely have these.
What do we do?
This is Jeff Bezos
of Amazon saying,
"if you want to
be inventive, you
have to be willing to fail."
He doesn't just say this.
He says this in every
interview that he gives.
And if you talk to
people at Amazon--
and we did for the book-- they
say this is his main mantra.
To encourage a
culture of failure.
But failure means trial and
failure, trial and error.
What do we mean by all this?
Let's think about the
two different ways
that you can face the world.
You can have a
performance mindset,
or you can have a
learning mindset.
A performance mindset is when
you're thinking, all right,
this is what I'm
going to demonstrate.
I'm going to
demonstrate mastery.
demonstrate competence.
A learning mindset
is when you're
going to learn mastery
and learn competence.
It's a completely different
way of figuring out
where you're going.
Now, as I show you
the next quote, which
is another of my favorite
pieces of the book,
just because it's
so implementable--
think about it in
terms of yourself,
when you can say something
like this yourself.
And think about it in terms
of when you can say something
like this to
somebody that you're
working with together
on a project.
As you're working
together on a project,
you can describe a
project this way.
These are exact words
that our researcher used.
"You'll probably learn a
lot, but you'll probably
make a bunch of mistakes,
get a little confused,
and maybe feel a
little dumb at times."
Now, I'm actually asking
you this question.
What does that
make you think of,
either when you say
to yourself or when
you get this kind of
instruction from somebody?
What kind of mindset
does that put you in?
What?
AUDIENCE: Relief.
SENIA MAYMIN: Relief.
Why relief?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SENIA MAYMIN: You can't mess
up much worse than that.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Freedom to take risks.
SENIA MAYMIN: Freedom
to take risks.
That's how I feel
about it as well.
And what happens if you
don't say this to somebody?
It's just not implied.
That's what I'm getting at.
There's nothing implied
about this kind of attitude
if you don't actually say it.
At Joie de Vivre,
Chip Conely's company,
one of the things he did is
he had a mistake-of-the-month
club.
So he actually
would reward people
who had the biggest
learning from a mistake.
Who does this?
A lot of companies do this.
You do this.
37 Signals, which is a
super company, does this.
Amazon really, really
invigorates their people
to do this.
But the part of it that you may
not think about it as often--
So even if you have thought
about these kinds of concepts,
how can I get into
a learning mindset?
If I'm messing up, how can I
think about it as learning?
One of the ways that we most
love to think about this
is, how can you carve this
kind of boomerang for others?
How can you make others, by
saying something like that,
or by giving them the
permission and the freedom,
think about this
kind of mindset?
We're giving you
one more exercise.
And it's the last one.
And why are we giving
you these exercises?
We told you you'd walk
away with three tools,
and we want you
to practice them.
Even though we're only giving
you 30 seconds to two minutes.
But please, turn to the
person next to you and let's
talk about when taking on a
learning mindset for yourself
or for someone you work
with would be helpful.
30 seconds per person.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SENIA MAYMIN: OK.
Learning mindset.
You and the learning mindset.
What is something you
heard from your partner
that you might be
able to implement?
Or what's an insight
that you have
in terms of how you can get
into the learning mindset?
So the comment is, for
example, in this presentation,
just coming to it and having
more of a learning mindset
rather than critical thinking.
I find that too,
especially if you practice
a sport or a hobby-- So I
really love ballroom dancing.
And sometimes I'll go
to a beginner class.
And it is somewhat beginner.
But I can have that
critical mindset.
Like, oh, that's boring,
or that's boring.
Or I can say, what
else can I learn?
So questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Earlier you mentioned
something about that there
was a big difference between
managers [INAUDIBLE].
MARGARET GREENBERG: We don't
know which way the arrow goes.
But one of the things
we will tell you is we
had to throw out a
whole piece of the data.
We also had the managers
take the assessment and say,
I give frequent recognition
and encouragement.
And what happened was
we then compared it
with the employees' response.
And they didn't match up.
So the employee said,
no, I'm not getting much.
And the manager was saying,
I give frequent recognition
and encouragement!
So really, we tossed out
the manager feedback.
Because when it comes
to frequent recognition
and encouragement, whose
opinion matters most?
It's the receiver
that's receiving it.
So just a quick
recap on the tools.
There's 31 tools in
"Profit from the Positive."
We gave you just three
in this last hour.
Trick yourself into
getting started.
FRE.
And then don't quit, just
quit being an expert.
OK you're in perf season,
right, here at Google?
Yes?
Well, guess what?
We've heard that performance
reviews are really painful.
We've heard it from managers.
We've heard from employees.
We've heard from HR folks.
So we devote a whole
chapter, actually,
to performance reviews.
We call it "Change
'Em or Chuck 'Em."
And one of the tools within
this chapter is called Preview,
Don't Just Review, Performance.
And this really borrows
from sports psychology
around visualizing success.
So if you're curious on how to
make the dreaded performance
review less painful,
definitely read Chapter Seven.
And then one other tool
that we didn't get to do
is Increase Your Odds.
There's some research
around when and where.
Those of you that
rely on others.
You might be an
individual contributor,
and you don't necessarily
have people that report you,
but you rely on others
to get your work done.
You need things from them.
You're more apt to get
what you need and get
what you want if you give the
person a triggering event.
And tell them where
and when you'd
like that piece
of work delivered.
So if I say to you,
Rebecca, will you
please get me that
analysis tomorrow?
Twice as likely if I
say to you, Rebecca,
can you give me that analysis
by 10 o'clock tomorrow morning?
In fact, even if you
can email it to me
or bring it to my office
on a flash drive, whatever.
Twice as likely to
get what I want.
So a couple other free
tools we just snuck in there
if we had time.
So here we go.
This is our website,
ProfitfromthePositive.com.
There are a lot of free tools.
This is someone that definitely
has a learner mindset.
She's going to be
the next, maybe, CEO.
Google maybe?
She'll break that glass
ceiling maybe after all.
But a lot of free tools there.
We also have a Facebook
page by the same name.
And we'll also stay here,
answer any other questions.
We're going to be
here for a while.
We'll also be happy to
inscribe your books for you.
And really, thank you.
It's been such an
honor to be here today.
We can't tell you.
Thank you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]